well the reason why sometimes they can  is because the other side thinks it's  completely reasonable and willing to be  reconciled but the other lot aren't and  actually one of the arts the art of  negotiation or is to lead the  negotiation so that you get people to  understand the other person thinks as  they do for reasons that aren't totally  unreasonable and that actually see it  from their perspective and actually you  start then to understand the possibility  of reconciliation because you actually  understand there is something to be  reconciled with and that's definitely  the problem in the israeli-palestinian  issue if you polled the majority of  people in Israel Palestine each side  would say we want peace in a two-state  solution right the people would vote for  that if you Satan do you think you'll  get it they'd say no if you ask them why  they're so because they also I don't  want it so I would say you can lead  people to reconciliation by that method  yeah